moving now to Waco Texas where former
president Donald Trump held his first
big 2024 campaign rally on Saturday
attacking all the investigations against
him now we are still waiting to hear
from a grand jury here in New York while
a special counsel bills a case for
possible federal charges but over the
weekend Donald Trump falsely claimed
that the Manhattan D.A had dropped the
case against him that is not true Robert
Costa has more
when they go after me they're going
after you former president Donald Trump
defying and attacking those
investigating him on Saturday
prosecutorial misconduct is their new
tool and they are willing to use it at
levels never seen before
in our country he opened the rally in
Waco Texas signaling support for those
who violently stormed the capital after
the 2020 election
playing a video with January 6
defendants singing a rendition of The
Star-Spangled Banner as he stood with
his hand to his heart
Trump's incendiary push forward comes
amid concern about potential violence
after Trump called for protests if
indicted by the Manhattan grand jury
investigating falsification of Records
relating to hush money payments made in
2016 to adult film star Stormy Daniels
Trump then escalated his rhetoric
posting about potential death and
destruction should he be charged and
labeling district attorney Alvin Bragg
an animal the D.A received a death
threat on Friday in a letter sent to his
New York office Trump's lawyer Joe
takapina wouldn't defend his clients
posts on Sunday including a recently
deleted one with Trump holding a
baseball bat I think that was an
ill-advised post that one of his social
media people put up but maintained
Trump's innocence regarding any payments
there is no crime here there's not even
a bad act lawmakers who've been briefed
by the FBI say authorities are keeping a
close eye on events the horrific
activities that took place on January
6th God willing will not see them
repeated this week should any one of
these cases move forward and Trump
the special counsel's investigation of
January 6 several top Trump aides will
now be compelled to testify including
former white house chief of staff Mark
Meadows and former National Security
officials Robert O'Brien and John
Ratcliffe all of this increasing the
pressure on Trump Gail
more to come thank you very much Bob
Costas